why don't we just get to know Alexa a
bit Alexa hello hello on the human team
job or intelligence questionable rich
read height not six four
my name is in Excel I know about lots of
things so full of us of coffee
what is thirty-two times pi I don't even
know what PI is Alexa what's three plus
two the sum of three and two is five
you're giving her really easy questions
play a song skull Club by I guess mob
that old flavor what's your prosper it's
spelt wrong and they would it myself
come quickly your hands of a Grammy come
on yeah I got it Alexa play skull club
skull club by The Glitch Mob
[Music]
I'm not there you do know you've got to
you should why is it with me Alexa
please turn off all the lights okay
who won that you have to be electorate
jokes he hates my jokes so so my
watching she's had a baby she she had a
six-day labor
everyone's like poor wife and my poor
wife why my poor wife because I I had to
pay for parking come on
tell us a joke I've recently decided to
sell my vacuum cleaner Paul it does is
gather dust
it's a really good joke is it the jokes
are on the same standard as yours I
would say maybe just below but she
didn't laugh at her own joke so at least
like half a point for professionalism
I like sir while down by John no problem
I'm happy to help how are we marking
this is if he's funny his own jokes
funny